well novelty is not necessarily good or
nice novelty is complex that's what it
is
and so I see really a concatenation of
tendencies and forces here at the end
it's only going to get weirder the level
of contradiction is going to rise
excruciating even beyond the
excruciating present levels of
contradiction so I think it's just going
to get weirder and weirder and weirder
and finally it's going to be so weird
that people are going to have to talk
about how weird it is and at that point
novelty theory can come out of the woods
because eventually people are gonna say
what the hell is going on it's just too
nuts it's not enough to say it's nuts
you have to explain why it's so nuts our
own decision to view the universe as
dead as inanimate as unintelligent
allowed us permitted us to dissect it to
use it and and deny its validity outside
of human purpose now the consequences of
living like that is coming back to haunt
us you know we have almost destroyed our
home we have almost cut the earth from
beneath our own feet
so this impulse toward the dynamic and
the nd archaic is a survival instinct
the good news is that as primates we're
incredibly adaptable to change put us in
a desert we survive put us in the jungle
we survive under Hitler we survive under
Nixon we survive we can put up with
about anything and it's a good thing
because we're going to be tested too
the limits the breakdown of anything and
this is why the right wing is so alarmed
because what they see going on is the
breakdown of all tradition all order all
sanction norms of behavior and they're
quite right that it's happening but
they're quite wrong to conclude that it
should be resisted or is somehow evil
the mushroom said to me once it said
this is what it's like when a species
prepares to depart for the stars
you don't depart for the stars under
calm and orderly conditions it's a fire
in a madhouse and that's what we have
the fire in the madhouse at the end of
time this is what it's like when a
species prepares to move on to the next
dimension the entire destiny of all life
on the planet is tied up in this we are
not acting for ourselves or from
ourselves we are we happen to be the
point species on a transformation that
will affect every living organism on
this planet at its conclusion
[Music]
[Music]
you